that's what gentlemen do we shoot it off
your childhood sex oh you didn't know
haha well you have been missing out my
friend okay
a spare part box so I mean I've dilute
[ __ ] and shed cuz I love what whoa what
happened to you Jennifer or poofy or
sugar cakes sugar cakes I'll go with
sugar cakes pour sugar cakes uh I mean
he only bought it the marker again shut
up shut up
let's sick of that [ __ ] marker I said
Clark must live oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
go down go down turn around ready okay
now
Tigra nade
hi I'm on your side hi hi I'm on your
side
well that went well
why hey J says
what a what a useless your name never
[ __ ] explode anything you batch you
can't land but you chose to die why do
they keep following [ __ ]
there we go there we go wake up it is
chill after limps if there's that and
load more load if you don't like it then
you shoulda put a boot on it if you
don't like it then you should put your
boot on it boom bam bam all right I'm
done more alert if you want to load that
then you shoulda put a bird on it if you
want to look at it then you share the
bird of build on it
whoa what's going on in here
don't make me kill you oh it's handsome
now oh you're gorgeous
Wow hey don't shoot
there we go no no bad babies bad babies
but bad babies stop doing that sending
my house good
hey our dog - really well okay what's
happening in this shed
whoa look at that it's like a dragon
call I love dragons hope I can ride it
I love the soundtrack sulphide it's
gorgeous
oh shut oh [ __ ]
I got done I'll just chill here how do
you see my dance I shut that coming
double chair no not the babies don't you
dare stay down [ __ ]
what Oh Joe don't know girl food of them
what the [ __ ] oh it's in my nipple
oh no he went in my nipple oh that was
close
no bat bat bat bat bang
since then what the [ __ ] is going on
here
alrighty then
I need a keycard and set it don't worry
they're just full of trash and pizzas
filled of Awesome you'd think some of
this stuff will break when Isaac just
stomps on it but nope let's check out
this door Bruce what is that
there we go quite splendid hello hello
lovely weather I was just coming from
the outside I just woke up in a quite
quite well
egg place and I just want to talk about
Mike Webb eh it doesn't work
[ __ ] well I just wanted to yes my
Kinesis abilities on this i just wanted
to [ __ ] he doesn't work kidneys is that
[ __ ] can this that [ __ ] can eat that
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did I just do oh it's a
love a love it hello well it's y'all a
giant drill blocking my way out not
worry about it maybe I can lower the
safety gates
allowance blender
all right that one
whoa whoa whoa this is not a prep
whoa and there's a men's what I can't do
that
no stop you're a bug what it says stasis
night sets stats at Jakes on dive shot
night nine Wow
what the [ __ ] am I supposed oh hello
stop no I like this
oh I get it I got it Pence's a genius
yes yes what you gonna do I have shampoo
and you don't Oh what's up
chomp that [ __ ] jump that's [ __ ]
how about Elliot ah dad what wait no
what did he say I'm awesome is that it
oh well I'm [ __ ]
it was nice knowing y'all oh [ __ ] hello
row bed nice a haircut today
alright I got that spin I got to do it
three times
no back up back up
no one likes it
I don't have any state says [ __ ] jay
says cries I suck at that shut up let me
shoot that thing alone oh [ __ ] alright
alright I did it I did it I'm I didn't
I'm gonna did s you know I'm not doing
here that bunny had a bad day
I made him health back what stop stop
I don't like you I don't like your
friends I don't like your face
Oh No
and fun laughs Wow with the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you cereal
because I don't even have a cereal right
now
babies
but I didn't tell the Justin Bieber was
in this game what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out Justin Bieber
[Music]
yeah what job Justin Bieber that's rock
oh that shit's intense man oh what's
what you gonna do now Justin what you
gonna do now I just beat that giant
drill what you gonna do Justin you gonna
make another pop single aren't ya
well that's okay I'll probably buy it
what no one told me I could do [ __ ]
cooler but how the hell did I do that
make me do that again
I want to calibrate that whoa I can do a
collab intern oh my [ __ ] god how the
hell do I do cool a bit oh I'm sorry I
don't know what it's called English I'm
just gonna keep colleague collaborator
do it they're gonna be done Oh what the
[ __ ]
hello Fran right oh it's my friend
pam pam pam pam Mike I'll kill your
friend what you gonna do about it
I killed chance I killed Jesus they do a
lot of damage
I don't sign up for this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that
no no it's gents again dance mop pad
that is one sexy mama
like Isaac that's one sexy base alright
so that was dead space 3 them up
I didn't team up with co-op but maybe I
well and when I actually pay the game
get out okay
well if you guys wanted me to play the
original playthrough when it comes out
and I think February 5th
maybe please leave a comment down below
and I'll be I'll be sure to do this so I
think I'll probably play it regardless
nevertheless thank you for watching bros
lucky fairies if you enjoyed subscribe
to come to earth today and i'll see you
next episode / make every breath
[Music]
Oh